she touches him tenderly on the face and
he leans into it and starts sucking his
thumb in a previous video I discussed
how Michael may have been traumatized by
seeing his sister Judith perform sexual
acts when he was young and this was the
root of all of his issues and likely the
motivation behind killing her in the
opening of the original Halloween it
seems that whatever the cause Art's
issues around women go even crazier
because he cuts off the baby lady's
scalp and breast to turn himself into a
maternal figure which is how he greets
tera's sister Victoria when she comes
into the building to search once again
he struggles with the locked door before
going outside to decapitate the
Exterminator coworker who had come for
backup honestly if art hadn't gotten to
him the guy's head was probably coming
off before long one way or another back
in the warehouse he sneaks up on
Victoria and tries the old Suffocation
via Saran Wrap routine just like in the
terrifier shores it takes a while but
like the woman in the short Victoria
realizes she can tear a hole in the
plastic and I love how dumbfounded art
looks that his plan failed so close